[Musique]
la campagne électorale a noté une phrase
de monsieur fabius si nous avions six
mois de plus avoir les élections nous
serions assurés du succès ce soir dans
notre série de portraits de campagne
fernand tavarès nous fait entrer chez
jean marie le pen
jean-marie le pen en privé père de trois
filles 17 22 et 26 ans le président du
front national comme beaucoup de leaders
politiques passionnés consacre plus de
temps aux réunions électorat qu'à son
foyer c'est pourquoi des retrouvailles
comme celles ci sont jalousement
protégés une chaise vide celle de
l'épousé de la mer qui a repris sa
liberté de ce fait les relations père
enfants se sont modifiées les familles
papa c'est souvent le père fouettard
celui pourtant menace
des enfants si jamais elle ne travaille
pas bien c'est apparemment ils n'ont pas
l'air d'avoir peur de
mon passé quelqu'un non vraiment je suis
fier vraiment je suis très fier je suis
vraiment très heureuse de m'appeler vous
êtes le pen est plus en plus mon père ne
nous a jamais forcer à penser quoi que
ce soit et guy ne nous a jamais
pratiquement par les politiques ou dit
il faut penser ça ça ou ça je pense
qu'on a décidé de nous mêmes cette
attitude gentil drôle qui danse qui aime
s'amuser malheureusement quelques rues
de choses à faire on se voit rarement
député européen et président de groupe
jean marie le pen au parlement de
strasbourg surveille de très près toute
question touchant à l'immigration ainsi
à la récente proposition d'autoriser la
libre circulation des personnes à
l'intérieur de la communauté jean-marie
le pen a émis des réserves évidemment
tout à fait favorable à l'ouverture des
frontières à l'intérieur de nos propres
pays
mais nous sommes au contraire partisans
de certaines définitions des frontières
européennes et d'un contrôle strict des
migrations qui pourrait venir de
l'extérieur nous serions submergée par
l'immigration si nous n'y mettons
en effet des contrôles très sévères
ceci au détriment non seulement de notre
propre indépendance mais même au
détriment de dudu dire monde derrière
jean-marie le pen gustave bordés a élu
sur la liste du front national ce député
européen d'origine roumaine est il ou
non un espion à la solde de les pays de
l'est pour espionner quoi dans un
parlement qui n'a strictement aucun
pouvoir et qui consacre son temps à
voter des résolutions
humanitaire à condition qu'il s'agisse
de problèmes qui se passe au chili au
nicaragua ou en afrique du sud c'est un
petit peu c'est un petit peu comme si un
marin suisse avait transmis les plans du
sous-marin helvétique l'humain au cours
de ses meetings de campagne jean marie
le pen y plaide aussi pour un certain
nombre de prix
sécurité famille protection d'un
nationalité française emploie pour les
français plutôt que de combat jean marie
le pen préfère parler philosophie être
français d'abord c'est quel sentiment
l'esta sentiment de fierté de ce qu'ont
fait nos ancêtres ce qui nous a été
légué et fierté aussi de la tâche qui
est la nôtre de
d'assurer le rayonnement de notre pays
et d'apporter par là même au monde la
culture humaniste dont nous sommes en
quelque sorte les vecteurs aides
apportées par là même à au monde un
élément de vérité
[Musique]